inde pays de la contemplation yoga et
méditation
quand nous nous sommes installés ici il
ya trois ans nous avions ce cliché en
tête et puis il a fallu se rendre à
l'évidence
autour de nous c'était le chaos qui
régnait
à bombay semaine de travail se termine
toujours par un embouteillage sur le
front de mer
embarquons dans le premier taxi qui
passe une vieille ambassador
[Musique]
au volant
ramesh 26 ans de conduite est à mes
côtés une jeune consoeurs indiennes à la
plage du centre-ville
ok c'est parti
vous qu'est ce que l'on fête le week end
je veux au temps et au centre commercial
avec ma femme
je ne prends qu'un jour de congé le
dimanche
comme la plupart des habitants de bombay
dix minutes de route et nous voilà
coincé dans un bouchon
voici ce qui ralentit la circulation
nous sommes dans le quartier huppé de
banderas
j'adore mon quartier
le carnaval annuel basson blanc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les habitants de bombay ne manque jamais
une occasion de faire la fête impossible
de traverser cette ville un samedi ou un
dimanche sans tomber sur une grande
manifestation culturelle ou religieuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'organisatrice de cette fête de
quartier est né à bombay d'un père
anglais et d'une mère indienne
j'aimerais bien vous montrer le char
derrière c'est là que se trouvent nos
plus jolies filles
elle a aussi des aïeux portugais un
métissage typique de cette ville est
plutôt explosif
c'est notre moulin rouge le mouleur
aujourd'hui
vous voulez les rejoindre
non merci je ne pense pas assez bien
la fête n'a rien de traditionnel on se
croirait plus au brésil en inde c'est le
nouveau visage de bombay
[Musique]
c'est la première fête de ce genre à
bombay c'est une façon de montrer que
notre petit quartier est plein d'énergie
et de vitalité
[Applaudissements]
avec keane djalma consoeurs indiennes
nous nous échappons du cortège pour
profiter du coucher de soleil sur la
grande plage du centre-ville le calme
enfin
toad indien dans l'eau bombay est
entouré par la mer mais la plupart de
ses habitants ne savent pas nager
le parent ne nous encourage pas faire de
sport ils se disent qu'il ya très peu de
chances qu'on devienne des champions un
jour et donc on gagne notre vie grâce au
sport ils préfèrent nous pousser à
devenir médecin ingénieur hommes ou
femmes d'affaires
il y a une autre bonne raison de ne pas
se baigner à bombay
qu'est ce que c'est c'est du verre
on trouve de tout dans l'eau au fond il
ya des bouteilles d'alcool et des tas
d'ordures
et quand la marée descend ses ordures
apparaissent la plage ressemble alors à
une immense décharge
donc les gens jettent leurs détritus
dans l'eau oui si vous aller un peu plus
loin vous verrez que ceux qui vivent au
bord de la mer sont servent comme d'une
poubelle
et personne ne nettoie non personne
cela n'empêche pas les gamins de se
baigner la pollution ici fait partie du
paysage c'est vous et touché l'eau avec
la main comme ça
voilà parfait
moi je viens tous les samedis vous êtes
de bombay
non j'en l'état voisin je rentre bientôt
chez moi
je vous ramener une photo de cette plage
pourquoi
je la trouve magnifique
la plage est aussi le territoire de
jeunes vendeurs à la sauvette ça ce sont
deux fois et pod
et tu écoutes quoi avec
ces données les oiseaux
cela signifie apprécié chaque instant de
ta vie
[Musique]
c'est un tube de bollywood le cinéma
indien
devenu un des hymnes des habitants de
bombay
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est c'est la dsd vima je
les trouvais dans l'eau
[Musique]
la ds retournera au fond de l'océan
jusqu'à la prochaine marée
à la tombée de la nuit sur la plage de
tchô pâtit une fête foraine place
[Musique]
leur pack coûte moins d'un euro et le
tour de ronde 10 centimes
les machines sont actionnés à la main
grâce à des garçons qui se jette dans le
vide accroché aux balançoires
le plus casse cou ce surnomme lui-même
spiderman indien
je fais ça depuis que j'ai 10 ans
ça me fait plus peur
faudrait surtout pas qu'il mette des
moteurs
on se retrouve au chômage
[Musique]
moi je n'aime pas ça mais mes enfants
adorent
je n'étais pour eux
à quelques kilomètres au nord sur la
plage changement d'ambiance
de la musique techno retenti elle vient
de la terrasse de ce restaurant
côté rue des vigiles gare de l'entrée
le patron nous accueille
bienvenue chez russe
cet endroit vous appartient oui depuis
trois ans maintenant un biais qui à 35
ans en ce moment on a une soirée coucher
de soleil venait voir on va passer par
le restaurant
[Musique]
la famille de vie qui possède plusieurs
restaurants comme celui-ci
et des hôtels de luxe
bienvenue dans l'homme qui brille
le marché du loisir ne cesse de croître
de plus en plus de gens sortent les
jeunes apprécient la bonne nourriture
l'alcool et la nouveauté
il n'est que 18 heures et sur la
terrasse la jeunesse dorée et branchée
se lâche
[Musique]
je vous présente dhiba et son émis elles
vont venir avec nous sur le toit venait
dans les coulisses du restaurant accès
privé au toit de l'immeuble vous avez vu
les gens qui dansent à la tête
à droite vous allez voir la vue est
superbe on voit c'est fantastique
[Musique]
sur la plage les jeunes des environs
regarde les yeux écarquillés cette fête
inaccessible
le cocktail coude ce 10 euros une
semaine de salaire pour la plupart des
habitants de bombay
[Musique]
je suis heureux de voir ça vous voyez
les gens sur la plage et s'amuse le
profil de la musique elle permet de
briser les barrières sociales c'est très
rare et ça me fait plaisir de participer
à ça
et vous trouvez vraiment que les
barrières sont brisés là
mais bien regardez vous même ils sont
sur la plage ils dansent ils écoutent de
la musique sans nom n'aurait pas ça
c'est un début
à bombay le prix des loyers est tel que
même les jeunes branchés vivent chez
leurs parents et doit donc rentré à une
heure décente la fête chez aux russes se
termine à 22 heures
le lendemain nous prenons l'argent ferry
il quitte toutes les demi heures le
centre-ville
regarde celui-là il immense
celui que nous prenons emmène un groupe
de gamins en classe de mer la
responsable du groupe via dirige une
entreprise de location de bateaux et le
dimanche elle s'occupe d'enfants
défavorisés cela vise à bombay et
pourtant ils n'ont jamais vu l'océan
ça continue loin l'océan
mais comment veux tu que je le sache
il faudra qu'on raconte à papa et à
maman ce voyage en bus sur l'eau
ils demandent s'il vient monde au delà
de l'horizon ici n'est que la mer c'est
la première fois qu'ils vont sur l'eau
ce qui leur plaît le plus j'ai
l'impression c'est sous les garde-côtes
ce sont des enfants comme il en existe
des dizaines de milliers à bombay leurs
parents sont ouvriers du bâtiment ils
viennent travailler quelques mois sur
les grands chantiers de la ville et dès
qu'ils n'ont plus de travail ils
repartent pour trouver du travail
ailleurs alors évidemment leurs enfants
ne vont pas à l'école et les occasions
s'amuser pour ces gamins sont très très
grave
après une heure de traversée nous
rejoignons la base nautique ou zia a
marre ces voiliers
d'eptica marrant et deux voiliers de
croisière qu'elle vient d'acheter en
france
nous essayons d'attirer les habitants de
bombay ici pour découvrir la voile ce
qui est une nouveauté ce sont les
premiers bateaux de plaisance importés
en inde
lui il va plus vite que nous
monsieur est ce qu'on peut rattraper ce
bateau
[Musique]
allez c'est à vous de tenir la barre
mais
regarde bien pour toi
aidez
la plupart des gens ne comprennent pas
aussi vite que
mes propres parents avaient peur que je
m'approche de l'eau je devais aller
apprendre la poêle en cachette
bombe est une péninsule entourée d'eau
mais ses habitants ont encore peur de la
mer nous voulons apprendre à ses enfants
apprivoiser l'on sait plus important que
l'apprentissage des techniques de
navigation
[Musique]
nous laissons les enfants à leurs cours
de voile est sur le chemin du retour
vers bombay escale à elephant island une
île située à une heure de ferry au large
de la ville
les gens viennent ici avec ces petits
bateaux qu'ils amarré au ponton
manoj et guide le dimanche et pêcheurs
en semaine l'heure de traverser pour
rejoindre elephant à dissuade les
touristes étrangers de s'y rendre mais
deux millions d'indiens la visite chaque
année aujourd'hui manoche accompagne
vikash fonctionnaires et père de famille
nombreuse
vous venez sur cette île pour visiter
l'île et profiter de ce dimanche avec
les enfants
c'est la première fois que vous venez
mais mes amis sont venus plusieurs fois
déjà
c'est un endroit très populaire et très
populaire je peux vous prendre en photo
pourquoi vous voulez une photo de nous
ça nous fera un souvenir vous nous
prenez bien photo vous on montrera au
monde de notre famille qui n'ont pas pu
venir les amis français qu'on a
rencontrés sur l'île d'éléphants temps
les portugais ont découvert cette île au
xviie siècle puis les britanniques l'ont
occupé de l'époque coloniale il reste
quelques souvenirs vous voulez une
chaise à porteurs c'est une augmenté il
ya 120 marche
quand les portugais ont découvert ligne
une immense statue d'éléphants trônait
sur la colline ils ont tenté de
l'emporter avec eux mais elle est tombée
au fond de l'océan les britanniques ont
ensuite transformé l'île en avant-poste
militaire pour protéger bombay
ce canon a été installé par les anglais
en 1918 il y en a deux un ici est le
deuxième de l'autre côté de l'île
la visite et surtout le prétexte à une
escapade loin du tumulte de la ville
bombay est une ville très active pendant
les week-ends et surtout le dimanche
les gens préfèrent passer du temps dans
des endroits tranquilles comme ici pour
passer du temps en famille
sans que personne ne les dérange
personne ne les appelez non plus le
téléphone c'est juste pour la musique et
pour s'amuser
la musique d'un polype woods toujours
[Musique]
celle ci est une chanson d'amour
il a rama rallye
elle nous accompagnera tout au long de
la promenade
jusqu'au pique nique entre les singes
errants et affamés
[Musique]
il ya du poumon vert du sel et de la
chair de notre coco le tout passé au
mixeur
on a préparé les plats hier soir et
rajouter les épices ce matin et cela
semble plaire aux singes qui se
rapproche dangereusement
mais j'ai juste à m'approcher il va me
sauter dessus
fin de promenade
en redescendant vers le port les
amoureux ont une vue imprenable sur la
baie qu'est ce que vous regardez je
regarde les indh et pétrochimie
vous préférez regarder sac la mer non la
mer est très belle aussi mais j'aime
beaucoup les cheminées
parce que je travaille dans cette usine
les habitants de bombay sont si fiers de
leur boom industriel que pour eux ses
cheminées ne défigure pas le paysage au
contraire
à 17 heures le dernier ferry quitté leaf
en thaïlande pour le centre de londres
regardez c'est le héros de bombay et
musclé il a du style
ça c'est un bateau
les riches sont toujours hors de portée
et vous qu'est ce qui vous fait rêver
voyager partout
faire le tour de la terre tu es prendre
la plus belle photo du monde via
moi l'argent la fortune ça ne
m'intéresse pas il n'y a que mes enfants
et la famille qui coince
dernières photos souvenirs
le ciel s'assombrit
au loin la ville apparaît déjà lundi
approche à bombay les dimanches semble
encore tout court d'ailleurs
mana mana gic